Male: Please join me in
welcoming Salman Khan.
(audience applauding)
Welcome, Salman. Thank you so much.
Khan: Good to be here. Thanks a bunch.
Very exciting to be here.
So before I start, I'd like
to get a sense of where the
audience is and how much
they might know about Khan
Academy. How many of y'all
have either used it or
somewhat familiar with the
site to a certain degree?
Oh, very good, very good.
How many of you have
used it with your kids, your
kids actively use the site.
Oh, this is very exciting.
All right, very good.
So just to start off. There
were some of y'all that
didn't raise your hands.
To get everyone on the same
page, Khan Academy is most known for this
collection of videos and I'll
talk a little bit about how
all of this got started, but
I literally started making
for my cousins and so I'll
show a montage of those
videos and you'll see what
they feel like and then
you'll also see some of
the other video direction
we're going in, not all
of them are made by me
anymore and we're starting
to experiment with some
other styles. So, let me show
you what that looks like.
We could integrate over the
surface and the notation
usually is a capital sigma.
All these interactions are
just through the gravity
over interstellar or almost you
could call it intergalactic.
This animal's fossils are
only found in this area of
South America, a nice clean band here.
Notice this is an aldehyde
and it's an alcohol.
It's their 30,000,000
plus the $20,000,000 from
the American manufacturer.
They created The Committee
of Public Safety,
which sounds like a very nice committee.
Steven: This is not Eve.
Beth: No, Botticelli's portrayed
the ancient goddess of love.
Voiceover: This is 6x6x6 or 216.
LeBron: I'm told the humidity
makes it feel hotter. Why is this?
Khan: Excellent question Lebron.
Voiceover: Let's just like make it eleven.
Khan: Play with the pendulum
and get a feel for how it moves.
Voiceover: Function as a bridge rectifier.
Voiceover: 1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8.
Khan: If this does not blow your
mind, then you have no emotion.
(audience laughing)
Khan: I can ... I can always tell
the intelligence of an audience
based on how much they
appreciate Euler's identity,
so y'all have ... y'all have
passed that, passed that.
So just to give a snapshot
of where we are now,
we've reached 75 million
unique students since kind of
this adventure began.
Over ... I think actually
the numbers are now
240 million videos have been watched.
We actually just crossed our
billionth exercise. I know the
slide says 900 million,
but our billionth exercise
literally a couple of weeks
ago. We're being used in
20,000 classrooms and
what you saw now are just
the videos, but what I want
to do is rewind a little bit
and tell, talk about how all
of this got started and then
talk about where we see Khan Academy going
because we think it's a lot
more than just the videos
that I initially started
making for family.
So if you were ... If you
rewind back to 2004, I was a,
my background is originally
in computer science, but
I had gone to business
school. I now found myself,
I was an analyst at a hedge
fund and I had just gotten
married and I had some
family visiting me from
New Orleans, which is
where I grew up. They were
visiting me up in Boston
and while they were there,
it was three of my
cousins and their parents,
my uncle and aunt and
the oldest of my cousins,
Nadia, who was 12 years old
at the time, it just came
out in conversation at some
point that she was having
trouble in mathematics and
so I said, "Nadia, you seem
like a very bright young
woman. What seems to be
the problem?" and she said
it was unit conversion.
And I said, "You know, I'm
completely convinced that
you can tackle unit conversion."
and she thought it was
just one of these empty
pep talks. I could kind of
sense that she was rolling
her eyes inside of her brain
and so I said ... I kind of
viewed that as a little bit of
a challenge. So I said,
"Okay, how about this?"
"You go back to New
Orleans.", I'm in Boston.
"Every day after work for
me, after school for you,"
"I tutor you and we try to
get you past this threshold."
and I think she was excited
that someone was willing
to take this, the time out
for her and so she agreed
and so they went back to
New Orleans and long story
short, you know, every
day we worked together.
It was difficult at first. She
kind of psyched herself out,
convinced herself that she
was no good at mathematics,
but about a month into it, she
was able to ... things clicked
and she was able to catch
up. Then she actually started
to get a little bit ahead of the
curve, a little bit ahead of where
her class might be and at
that point I'd like to say I
became what I call a "tiger
cousin" and I called up her
school and I said, "You know,
I really think Nadia needs
to retake the placement
exam, go into the faster
math track." and they
said, "Well, who are you?"
(audience laughing)
"I'm her cousin." and, uh,
but you know it's a theme
that I guess you'll see
many times over the next few
minutes, but I've seen many
times over the last few
years starting with Nadia
is that the same girl who
entering 7th grade thought
she was no good in math
and thought that she couldn't
comprehend unit conversion,
by her sophomore year in
high school was taking
Calculus at the local
university and something we're
going to see over and over
again is that people who
thought they were bad at
something are able to just
if they're able to fill in
the gaps in their knowledge
are able to all of sudden race ahead.
But I was kind of hooked,
I worked with Nadia then I
started working with her
younger brothers. Then the
firm that I was working
for, I use "the firm"
very broadly, it was my
boss and his dog, we, uh,
the dog was the chief economist.
We ended up moving out
to northern California.
My boss' wife got a job as
a professor at Stanford Law
and the first Khan
Academy, most people don't
realize it because the
videos have kind of,
kind of have a life of their own,
the first Khan Academy was
actually a little piece
of software that I had
written for my cousins,
to kind of give them practice
problems. I noticed that
they didn't, they weren't really
proficient in a lot of things
that you would expect
someone in 5th or 6th or 7th
grade to know. I was
somewhat suspicious of
whether they were doing the
work, so I put a database
behind it and you fast
forward to 2006. I was at a
dinner party with a friend
and all my friends knew I
had this kind of crazy
project with my cousins
and I was showing off the
software that I had written,
this things that generate
exercises for them and they
all knew that I had this
project, but word had gotten
around in the family that
free tutoring was going on
and so I found myself now
tutoring every day after
work about ten or fifteen
cousins and family members
and whatever else and my friend he's like,
"Oh Sal, this software is
really cool but how are you
dealing with, you know,
being able to coordinate"
"all of these tutoring
sessions" and I'm like,
"You know, it's actually getting
really, really difficult."
and he's the first person to
tell me, "Well, there's this"
"YouTube thing. Why
don't you make some of,"
"Why don't you make videos
of some of your lessons,"
"put them up on YouTube,
maybe your cousins would"
"find it useful." and I
immediately thought it was a
horrible idea. I said,
"No, no, no, no, no."
"YouTube is for cats playing
piano. It's not for serious"
"mathematics.", but I literally
went home that weekend
got over the idea that it wasn't
my idea and I gave it a shot
and you know, those first
few videos were kind of on
algebra and pre-algebra and
whatever else and I made
about ten or twenty of
them. There were little
10-minute long videos and I
started telling my cousins,
"Look, if you're confused
about something, you"
"want to review something,
there's these videos that"
"are there for you" and
after about a few months,
I asked for feedback and
you know, they somewhat
backhandedly told me that
they preferred me on YouTube
than in person and viewing
the positive angle of that
feedback, I think it
actually made a lot of sense.
They were saying look, they
appreciated the time I was
spending with them. They
appreciated the tutorials,
but the first time that
you learn something, it's
stressful to have someone
say, "Oh are are, do you"
"understand this now?" or a
lot of times, you might be
in 7th or 8th or 9th grade
and you forgot some concept
from 4th or 5th grade and
you might be embarrassed
to tell your cousin and so you
can now review it at your own
time and pace. When people
coordinate time, you know,
they might have other things
going on in their day.
They might have a lot
of homework that night.
Now they could access the
content when they're ready,
when they're ready to access it.
So I view that as positive
feedback and I just kept
going adding more and more
and more and more content.
Then it became clear,
soon enough on YouTube,
that there were people who
were not my cousins who
were watching and you
know at first the comments
were just, you know, thank
you, this really helped,
I really appreciated this
and even that was a pretty
big deal. I don't know how
much time y'all have spent
on YouTube, but the
comments don't always be,
aren't always that positive.
(audience laughter)
or even G-rated and then
the comments got really
interesting. They started
to be things like, you know,
hey this is the reason why I
was able to go back to college,
this is the reason why I'm now
a physics major, this is the
reason why after leaving
the military I can go back
and major in engineering
and you know, I got crazy
e-mails. One family said,
"Thank you so much for this"
"resource. My entire family
prays for your entire family"
"every evening." and you
have to put things in
perspective. I was an
analyst at a hedge fund.
We didn't have a lot of
people praying for us.
(audience laughing)
Maybe our investors every now and then.
So I just kept going and
going and going. In 2008,
I set it up as a not for profit.
Even at that point, I didn't
really imagine that it
was, you know my I guess my
for profit career was going
well and I just assumed
that hey maybe I'll just
do the for profit thing.
I'll set this up as a not for
profit. Maybe at some point
I could get some grants for
it or maybe get a couple
of people to work on it, but
I didn't really think of that
as something that might
overtake my life, but then as
little as a year after that,
2009, it had taken over my life.
At this point, there were
several hundred thousand
people who were using the site
every month. I was getting
hundreds of e-mails every
week. I was sneaking away and
making videos in every kind
of free time that I had and so
I sat down with my wife. We
had a little bit of savings.
Sometimes I'm introduced
as a hedge fund manager
and I make it very clear now,
I was the analyst. There's a
different pay grade otherwise
it would have been a much
easier decision and I would be
dressed a little bit better.
(audience laughing)
But I was an analyst and so we
had some savings about enough,
about a year's worth of
savings, but we didn't own a
house, our son had just
been born but you know,
my wife understood that this
is kind of, had overtaken
my life and I said, "Look,
you know, someone's gotta"
"appreciate it in the next year."
We'll give ourselves a year,"
"someone should appreciate
that there's almost"
"infinite social return on
investment here. That I could"
"keep on making videos. We
could do the interactive"
"software, etc., etc. It could
reach millions and millions"
"and millions, maybe one day
billions of students." and so I
kind of took that leap of faith and
I think like a lot of entrepreneurial
stories, you start off very
naively optimistic. You're already
starting to talk to some
foundations, you just assume
yeah, this is a no-brainer
for them, they're definitely
going to fund this and they don't.
A few months go by and in
all honesty about nine months
went by and I started getting
pretty insecure and there
was even a night where I
started literally updating my
resume and thinking that I
would go back into the world
that I had come from and
right when I was, right around
that same time, I had some
... I had a place where
people could send in donations.
There was a little PayPal
link and I was getting
$50 donations, $5 donations
every now and then $100
donation would come in and
that did help pay the bills,
but we were digging into our
savings to the tune of about
5 or $6,000 a month and
right when that was happening
all of a sudden a $10,000
donation came in and so I
immediately see who this
is from, her name was
Ann Doerr. She was based in
Palo Alto. So I immediately
sent her an e-mail, I said,
you know, "Thank you so much
"for this very generous
donation. This is the largest"
"donation that the Khan
Academy has ever received."
"If we were a physical
school, you would now have a"
"building now named after you."
(audience laughing)
which I've now discovered
is quite inexpensive.
It gets you a bench at most universities.
And she immediately
e-mailed me back and said,
"Well, I'm fascinated by what
you're doing. Let's have lunch."
and so we literally, I think
it was like a week later,
we had lunch in downtown
Palo Alto in a little Indian
buffet restaurant and Ann
said, "Well, you know,"
"what are you trying to do?
What's your goal?" and I said,
"Look, when I filled out
the paperwork with the IRS,"
"they have a little line
that says mission statement"
"and I said, well I don't
know, a free world-class"
"education for anyone,
anywhere." and Ann said,
"Well, that's optimistic.
That's ambitious."
"How do you plan on
doing that?" and I said,
"Well, I want to keep making
videos, but I could imagine"
"building the interactive software
even more, the stuff that"
"I started making with my
cousins, feedback, dashboards,"
"tools for teachers, ways for
kids to communicate online,"
"we can internationalize
it, so anyone on the planet"
"can possibly access it."
and she said "Well, you know"
"this is strangely enough,
it seems like your on track"
"to do this. How are you
supporting yourself?"
and in as a proud of a way as
possible I said, "I'm not."
(audience laughing)
And so Ann kind of nodded
and we parted ways,
she got on her bicycle, I got
into my car and I drove home
ten minutes later I'm driving
into the driveway and I got
a text message from Ann and
it said "you really need"
"to be supporting yourself.
I've just wired you $100.000."
So, it was a good day.
(audience laughing)
And frankly that was
the beginning of a whole
cascade of stranger and stranger
events. You fast forward
two months, I was running,
you know I was like this
virtual teaching guy and I
was curious what could you
do with a physical environment
if it's not based on
lecture anymore and so I
had this little summer camp
where I had about twenty-five
middle school students
and I had six of them play a
game of Risk and then I had
the other, the remainder of the
students trade securities based
on the outcome of the game
of Risk and one 12-year-old
actually invented naked
shorting and I told them I could
introduce them to some people,
they could ... they could
do quite well. But, while that
was happening I got another
actually series of text messages
from Ann and at this point
I take her text messages very seriously.
(audience laughing)
They ... they, it was actually
hard to read but it read
along the lines of "I'm at
the Aspen Ideas Festival right
now. In the main pavilion.
Bill gates on stage talking
about Khan Academy last
five minutes" and so I
immediately boot the nearest
7th grader off of a computer
and I start looking for
evidence that this, what is Ann
talking about and I soon found
people tweeting about it.
I was finding even blog posts
were starting to come out,
in a few hours I was able to
find actual footage of the
event and Bill Gates on stage
with Walter Isaacson talking
about how he uses this thing
called the Khan Academy
with his kids, he uses it himself
which actually was a little bit
scary for me. Those videos were
for Nadia, not for Bill Gates.
(audience laughing)
And then I went home that
evening kind of just confused
and not sure what to do
next. I mean, do I call him?
Do I ... What's the protocol here?
And they left me in that
somewhat bizarre state for the
next two weeks and so two weeks
later I'm literally in the
world headquarters of the
Khan Academy which was our
walk-in closet and I was making
a video and then all of a
sudden I get a call from
Seattle. This is intriguing,
I answer the phone, "Hello."
and on the other side,
you know, "This is Larry Cohen.
I'm Bill Gates' chief of staff"
"You might have heard that Bill's a fan."
"Yeah, I heard that."
(audience laughing)
"If you have some time in
the near future, we would"
"love to fly you up to Seattle
and figure out how we can"
"support you." and at that
moment I was looking at my
calendar for the month, completely blank.
(audience laughing)
So I said, "Yeah, you know
I gotta cut my nails on"
"Wednesday, but other than
that I think I can fly up"
"and meet Bill Gates."
So all of that worked out,
went and met with Bill Gates.
They decided to support us,
be able to hire up a team.
Right around that same
time, we were also meeting
with the folks at Google. I
mean, all of these things were
just these independent events
that just came together
all at once. They also
decided to support us in a
significant way and about
this time two and a half years
ago, not that long ago,
we were up and running and
we were kind of ready to build
what I had first described
to Ann and what you see
here, this is kind of a,
I like to show this because
it kind of gives a framework
for how we think about how
kids can interact and learn
with the system. This is what
we call our knowledge map.
Each of those nodes are
concepts in mathematics,
so you saw the videos.
They go much broader than
mathematics. Right now
our interactive portion is
mainly math. Over time, we
hope that the interactive
will also be in quite possibly
every subject, but what
you see here is that the higher
you go, there are more basic
concepts and as students
show proficiency or mastery
in the more basic concepts,
it then moves them down to
more advanced concepts and
it's kind of an obvious idea,
it's how you would play a
video game. You master level
one, then you go to level
two. That's how you would
learn a martial art. That's
how you would learn a musical
instrument, but the thing that
I always point out is this
is not the way that you are
taught in a traditional classroom.
In a traditional classroom,
you group kids by age.
You push them through in
a kind of a assembly line
factory model and it's actually
no coincidence, this model
was developed really during
the industrial revolution.
At different points in time,
usually state mandated, you
kind of try to apply
information to them. Some kids
get the information, some
kids don't. Even if a kid gets
a "C" on say basic exponents,
that's and you identify
those weaknesses, you move
on to negative exponents
or fractions or something
more advanced, even though
you know that they had
weaknesses in something more
basic and the analogy I
draw there is imagine if you
were building a house and
you get the contractors and
you tell the contractors,
"Look, we have ... the state
tells me we have exactly three
weeks to build this foundation."
"Do what you can.", so the
contractor does what they can
You get the inspector to show
up after two, three weeks
and the inspector says,
"Well, yeah I don't know the"
"concrete's still a little bit wet
right over there. This part right"
"over here isn't quite up to
code. I would give it an 85%."
and you say, "Great, that's a
'C'. Let's build a first floor."
and you build a first floor,
you know, two weeks of you know
you tell the contractor, "Look,
you just have to spend two weeks."
"I don't care if the supplies
don't show up. I don't care"
"if it rains. Do what you
can." Inspector shows up, 75%.
"Great, let's build the
second floor" and you do that
floor after floor after floor
and then all of a sudden while
you're building the fourth
floor and the whole thing
collapses, you blame the
contractor. You say, "Oh my
God, I had a horrible
contractor." or maybe you say,
"Oh, we didn't inspect good
enough.", but the reality is
maybe those things were fine,
but the process was broken.
The inspector was identifying
weaknesses, but you
completely ignored them
and you moved onto the
next concept and this is
essentially what's happening
in our schools every day
and so what we're saying is,
look, instead of holding fixed
when and how long you have
to learn something and the
variable is how well you
learn it pretty much ensuring
that you end up with all of these
gaps that are going to make
you hit a wall later on in
your career, let's make the
variable how long you have to
learn it and when you learn
it essentially personalize the
instruction for your needs,
but the fixed thing is that
you have a high-level,
a high-level of mastery.
Now this is just an example
of what some of these
exercises look like. I
showed, you know, we mentioned
that a billion of these
have been done and I like to
show this one. This is kind of
like montessori for Calculus.
It kind of shows you that
you can change the slope of
the tangent line at any point
and by doing that you're
essentially plotting the derivative.
You know when I ... When we
started this whole thing,
I assumed Khan Academy was
just going to be this thing
outside of classrooms. You
know, the school system
was this beaurueacratic thing
with a lot of inertia, but
right when we got some of
that first funding, a local
school district reached out
to us, Los Altos, and said,
"Look, what would you do
with a 5th grade classroom,"
"now with your tools?" and we
said, "Look, we don't think"
"there's a reason to use
class time for this passive"
"one size fits all lecture.
Like, students can get it"
"On Demand". I told them
how my cousins liked that
even more and we can
use class time for more
valuable things, for
interacting with the teacher,
for peer to peer instruction.
The irony here is if the kids
can learn at their own time
and pace when they're not
in the classroom, the
classroom could become a more
human experience because
they had this technology
and somewhat surprising to us, they said,
"Yeah, this is exactly
consistent with differnentiated
instruction, mastery based
learning, these concepts
that have been in education
circles forever and we want
to do it." So, we started a
pilot and what you see here is
some of the dashboards
from that initial pilot and
it gives you an idea how
these classrooms could work.
So each row is kind of like
a spreadsheet, each row there
is a student in the class.
Each of those columns is one
of those concepts you saw
in that knowledge map.
Green means that a student is
proficient. Blue means that
they're working on it and
red means that a student is
stuck on it and the model
is the teacher can walk
around, it literally updates
in real time. It shows up on
their tablet and they can
say, "Okay, that student is
having trouble with exponents
3. There's a couple of
students who have already
mastered that, maybe I can set up
a little peer tutoring between
them or if they're still
having trouble, maybe I
can sit down and do a very
focused intervention or
maybe if a bunch of students
have already mastered a certain
concept, I can now do more
interactive maybe a project based
on, based on that type of a concept.
This next chart or graph,
I mean we have a ton of
dashboards for teachers, so
that we can really give them
the type of analytics, frankly
the type of analytics that
we were seeing before in the
marketing analytics or the
type of analytics that I had
when I was an analyst at a
hedge fund, we can finally give
that to a teacher so they can
in real time slice and dice
what all other students are up
to, but I like to show this
one because above and beyond
to showing a report, it talks
about a very powerful narrative,
essentially the same narrative
that I had first seen
with Nadia. The horizontal
axis there is just time.
It's just days on the site. The
vertical axis is just a count
of how many of those
modules a student has shown
proficiency in and each of
those lines is a student in a
classroom and what you
see is, just like any math
classroom, right when you
start there's a group of kids
very steep slope, they
start advancing really fast.
There's a group of kids in
the middle and then there's
a group of kids who are really
slow to start, those are
the flatter lines and in a
traditional model, you say oh
those kids who are racing
ahead, those are the honors
students. Those are the kids
who are, you know, gonna go to
to college, become engineers
and doctors and all the rest.
We have the kids in the middle
and there are kids, the slow
kids. Maybe those kids are the
remedial students, but what
we're seeing is if you let
every student learn at their own
pace, if you let them fill in
the gaps that you thought that
they weren't able to fill in
before. The same students that
we thought were remedial
ten days into the process or
mediocre ten days in the
process and this blue student
is one of them and it actually
clips off a little bit on the right,
but on the right it, even at
day 70-something you see that
there's a third best student,
but this student actually ends up
becoming the second best
student in the class and we're
seeing this over and over
and over again in every
classroom that we've worked
with, whether we're talking
about public schools, private
schools, rich neighborhoods,
poor neighborhoods, where
ever it is many of the kids
that even in the two months
that you thought were slow,
you thought were remedial,
you let them fill in that gap
even though it's in algebra
class, you let them make sure
they know their multiplication
tables, know they're
multiplying decimals, adding
fractions, negative numbers,
they can become the best
student in the class.
(audience applauding)
Right now, 20,000 classrooms
are using us in some
way shape or form. I want to
make it clear, all of this is
completely free, it's not for
profit. All these dashboards that
I'm showing you, you could start
using it with your cousins,
you can volunteer at your local
boys and girls club or your
local school and you can be the
coach and you would have the
same tools that the teachers
in Los Altos have, but with
that we like to remind ourselves
that still the bulk of our
users even though we have
400,000 in classrooms, the bulk
of our users, the other 5,500,000
are just people out there
just trying to tap into their
potential and what this next
video at least shows us and
hopefully shows you as well,
is just how much potential there
is out in the world if we just give
people the tools to actually tap into it.
Mark: My name is Mark Halverstedt.
Growing up, I was really
always a "C" student. I think
I was really pretty much always
pretty pitiful in school. I
don't think I've ever gotten
higher than a B+ in any math
class ever particularly.
I pretty much thought that
the only thing I was good
enough to do in college was
major in music and I went off
and I got a music degree
in saxophone, but I sort of
almost felt that it was more
I was getting it because I
was terrible at everything
else. I worked as a saxophone
player for a few years, really
what I wanted to do was do
electrical engineering and
the last thing that I remember
completely not getting was
trig identities. So, I went to
YouTube and I did a search
for trig identities and Khan
Academy was the first thing
that popped up. I watched a
bunch of videos in the trig
playlist to kind of get caught up to
speed. I watched all of the
videos in the calculus playlist.
I watched all the videos in
the physics playlist. I watched
a bunch of videos on dividing
decimals and even on a
subtraction by borrowing. I
watched a lot of videos on
arithmetic. That was in 2007.
I did that until the fall
of 2010 and then in the fall
2010, I took a leap. I decided
to go back to school and
went to Temple University,
majored in electrical engineering
getting a second bachelors
and keep in mind, I don't
think I've ever gotten above a
B+ in math classes and I was
really a straight "C" student
growing up and I just finished
this year, first year back
in college, I got a 4.0 GPA for
the entire year. I got perfect
scores on both of my Calc
final exams and also on
my Chemistry final exams. I
ended Calculus, Chemistry,
both Calculus classes, Calc I
and II and Chemistry with an
average higher than 100%.
There are some Khan Academy
videos that I probably
listened to the same concept
over twenty or thirty times
and there is no tutor in the
world I could have paid
to have sat next to me and
repeated the same thing
over twenty or thirty times
without at least them getting
a little bit judgmental
or at least them thinking like
oh, well this guy really is never
going to get this concept
and he should just give up.
Where the understanding
really happened was watching
those videos and also working
through the Khan Academy
software and everything. The
impact for me in my life,
I really see it growing
exponentially over the next twenty
or thirty years. So from the
bottom of my heart, thank you.
(audience applauding)
And Mark is now a junior
and still has a 4.0 GPA,
so he's doing quite well.
Maybe he'll apply for an
internship with some of you
guys, so keep a look out.
So the one thing that might,
some of y'all might have been
thinking about and I even
saw that map where some of
y'all are from is everything
that I've been focused on so
far has been the English
speaking world, the developed
world, but the implications
on the developing world
could be even larger where
you have lack of resources or
even if you have the resources,
you might not be able to
find teachers where the kids
have all sorts of, they're all at
different types of skill levels
and so we've started to have
other groups take what we're
doing, other not for profits,
for the most part but even
some governments, take our
stuff and start to deploy it
all over the world and these
are pictures of Khan Academy
being used in various
parts of the world and each
of these are exciting stories.
But the one for us that's
kind of been the most mind
blowing is the one up there
in the top right. You know,
I used to give talks like
this about a year ago and say
one day, this might be used
in Mongolia and about a little
after that I got an e-mail
from Mongolia. It was actually
from Zaya, the girl on the top
right and she actually sent
a YouTube thank you not too
different than what you saw from
Mark Halberstadt and I
assumed she must be a middle-
class girl. She has access
to YouTube and whatever else,
but then I read the e-mail in
more depth and it turned out
that there was a group from
Silicon Valley who in their
vacation time, a group of
engineers was going to Mongolia
and setting up a kind of a
computer labs in orphanages
and what you see there the
top right, those are girls
in a Mongolian orphanage
using Khan Academy and Zaya
was one of the orphans and
that by itself was cool enough
but then Zaya herself who is
now 17 and got so into it,
that she's our now, she's
now, this is a 17-year-old
orphan girl is now our prime
producer of content in the
Mongolian language. She is
essentially the teacher for
her country and so it's kind
of one of these surreal,
sci-fi type of things and so
what I want to show you now
is the direction we're going in,
in terms of internationalization.
We have 4,000 videos in
English. We now have 7,000
in, I think, twenty languages
and our goal is to frankly have
80,000 in twenty languages
and maybe more and maybe
even have regional specific
content and so this next
montage shows you a little
taste of what those other
videos look like and they're
already available on the
site, if you, at the bottom
there's a little bit of a drop down
and it ends with a little
part of Zaya's original video.
Zaya: I'm Zaya from
Mongolia. Your videos are so
interesting and funny. Make more lessons.
I watch that, I watch
that when I get lazy.
(audience applauding)
So I like to point out, I
mean you know it started with
me and my cousins, but I like
to emphasize that it's not
just me anymore. It's a team
of folks. We're approaching
40 people and I like to
emphasize I think we're in a
special time in history,
literally, a Gutenberg moment,
not even a once in a lifetime
opportunity. I literally think
it's a once in a millenia
opportunity where you could have
real reach and real scale
and what I point out is,
you know, our team over
the last year averaged 24
employees. We've been
growing quite fast, but we've
been able to reach 43
million unique students over
the past year and I point
out that if that was actually
drawn to scale, that second bar should be
20 kilometers high.
So, you know, big picture,
the original tagline on that
was just the necessities, but there was a.
You know, big picture,
education has traditionally
viewed as a very scarce thing,
a thing that's expensive,
a thing that really differentiates
between the haves and
have nots, even when people
did philanthropy, it was
always what do the rich
have? Well, that's expensive.
Let's create a cheaper
approximation of it and let's try
to give it to the poor because
they had nothing before
so it's better than nothing,
but what's exciting now is
I think we're entering a
reality where we don't even have
to give the poor a cheaper
approximation. We can give
students like Zaya and the
other girls in her orphanage
the exact same thing that
Bill Gates' children have, so
we're going into a world
where education isn't this
scarce thing, isn't this
expensive thing so ten, twenty
thirty years in the future, I
firmly believe that it will be
viewed as a human right and it
will be viewed as just one of
these necessitites like clean
drinking water, shelter or
electricity and with that I'd
just like to thank you for
having us here. Thanks a bunch.
(audience applauding)
Male: Wow.
Khan: Thanks.